one of the finest things about being a
baby is that our minds can be read by
others
without us needing to say anything
people around us will have a guess at
determining what we intend and typically
they'll get it right they'll correctly
surmise that we are craving some milk or
that the sun is shining in our eyes that
it's time for a snooze or that we want
to jiggle the keys again
this may be highly gratifying and
important to us in infancy but it can
set up dangerous expectations for the
rest of our lives
it can breed in us the sense that anyone
especially anyone who claims to care
about us
should be able to determine our deepest
aspirations and wishes without us
needing to save very much
we can stay silent
they will mind read
this explains a widespread tendency to
assume that others must know what we
mean and want without us having actually
told them anything clearly
we assume that our lover must know what
we're upset about
that our friends should realize where
our sensitivities lie
and that our colleagues must intuitively
grasp how we want things done in
presentations
furthermore we assume that if they don't
then it must be a sign that they are
being wicked deliberately obtuse or
stupid
and we are therefore justified in
falling into assault
that curious pattern of behavior whereby
we punish people for having committed
offences whose precise nature we refuse
to reveal to them
but in all this we have somewhere along
the path of our development forgotten
the fundamental importance of teaching
teaching isn't a distinctive profession
focused on imparting knowledge about
science and the humanities to the under
18s
it's a skill that we must put into
practice every day of our lives
and the subject we must laboriously and
patiently become experts in and deliver
lessons on
is called ourselves
what we like what we're scared of
what we're hopeful about
what we want from the world
and how we look for things to be
formatted
babies for all their intelligence and
charm
only care about a handful of things
an average adult has thousands of very
set ideas on a manner of all topics
from the right way to govern a country
to the right way to shut the fridge door
we should strive to deliver a few
seminars on our views before allowing
ourselves to grow resentful and sullen
yet how understandable in a sense if we
should fail so badly in our teaching
duties
we're not necessarily being lazy or
unkind
it's merely unbelievable that strangers
would actually require us to talk them
through yet another chapter of the dense
instruction manual of our deep selves
we never had to bother with all that in
the early years
we may be more nostalgic for our infancy
than we might have dared to imagine
one of the trickiest tasks we ever have
to face is that of working out who we
really are this book is designed to help
us create a psychological portrait of
ourselves with the use of some unusual
oblique entertaining and playful prompts
click the link on screen now to find out
more